I think it goes without saying the color I'm looking for,
but in case someone doesn't notice,
only reflections containing color.
And damn color.
Green,
Green.
My goodness,
nothing!
It's amazing,
Verde.
Only 5 people have achieved this challenge.
It is the most difficult challenge in TikTok soccer.
Literally.
You can fuck 1 day,
24 hours trying and you're not going to get it.
You need a lot of luck.
Green Green is 1 crazy thing,
Green Green.
But well,
you know,
if you want to try it and you can do it by miracle,
pass it to me.
Obviously I follow everyone who makes it,
is very difficult.
I don't know what to do anymore.
Green
Green,
please,
Green.
I really never wanted Green as much as I did these days.
Green,
Green.
Ah,
is incredible.
It is very,
very difficult,
far from impossible,
but very difficult.
It takes a lot of luck.
Green,
please Green Green.
Why is there so little Green on the planet?
Man,
I'm talking about the boys,
huh?
Why do so few World Championships have Green?
What do you have against the Green?
It is wonderful.
It is 1 color that transmits joy
and almost nobody has it.
And those who have it
in truth is almost entirely the Green Card,
as Celtic,
Wolfsburg,
Betis.
But no one has it,
almost no one.
Green.
Please Green,
Green,
Green Green.
Defense and justice.
Nothing,
nothing,
Green.
Definitely.
The people who have
After completing this challenge,
you have passed TikTok.
Definitely
I have reached the conclusion
of those of you who have completed this challenge,
you have passed the TikTok platform,
you can uninstall it now if you want to
because you have spent the whole game.
I still can't get it
Really,
huh?
It's impossible?
Green Host,
right? Huh?
I said it,
if you want to try and you succeed,
pass it to me.
I am following everyone who makes it,
that there have only been 5 in almost 1 month since we lasted
trying.
Try it